هذه القريه قد لا يوجد لها مثيل في العالم
كل ما نزلها ومبانيها لا تحتوي على ابواب
لكن ما هو سر وراء هذه العاده المتوارثه
منذ 10 سنين
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
عادات وشعوب
[موسيقى]
هناك
في ولايه مهاره الهنديه ثالث اكبر ولايات
الهنديه
حبيبي حبيبي
ان قدرات الشاني هائله فاذا قام احد
بالسرقه فسيمشي طوال الليل ويظن انه غادر
البلده لكنه سيكتشف في الصباح انه لا يزال
فيها
نالت القريه غير العاديه قسطا كبيرا من
الشهره بعد ان ظهرت
من ذلك الوقت
السكان هنا يؤمنون بان القريه لا تخلو من
حوادث السرقه فقط بل تخلو من السلوكيات
الخاطئه ايضا ولديهم ايمان بان من يرتكب
خطيئه سيتعرض لسبع سنوات ونصف من النحس
وسوء الحظ
شاركونا ارائكم هل شاهدتم سابقا منازل بلا
ابواب كما هو الحال هنا في هذه القريه